Hello there.
Now, I know what you're thinking.
Crikey, a black cat!
He's gonna bring me bad luck.
Shows what you know about luck.
Let's drop some knowledge.
Luck is different all around the world.
Like in Scotland where a black cat like me is considered very lucky.
Remember kids, don't try this at home.
Name's Bob, by the way...
...and this is the Land of Luck.
Morning, Gerry.
We work behind the scenes to create those wee lucky and unlucky moments...
...that make up your everyday life.
Like these guys, an entire team thinking up the jammy work...
...that kinda makes you feel like a million bucks.
Okay, maybe a hundred bucks.
Of course, then there's the other team...
...working on the not so jammy kind of luck,...
...and they sure love what they do.
Well, you humans are a complicated lot...
...and that's why things run so smoothly here...
because no human has ever set foot in this place.
And with a little bit of luck, they never will.
Uh, where am I?
Oh, you got to be kidding.